[Musik]
sie sind
hallo herzlich willkommen in sallys welt
werden wir wieder unsere auto hier
aufgebaut und möchten heute grillen und
zwar soll es leckere knoblauch kräuter
brot steaks vom grill geben ich freue
mich schon riesig darauf zuerst werde
ich jetzt mal einen pizzateig zu
bereiten falls es bei euch ganz schnell
gehen soll könnt ihr natürlich auch
einen fertigen pizzateig nehmen aber
kommt schon pizzateig zu machen ist echt
ganz einfach wenn ihr die zutaten dafür
habt und zwar verwendet ihr dafür fünf
gramm hefe einen esslöffel zucker
225 gramm wasser 450 gramm mehl etwas
salz und jetzt einen teelöffel pfeffer
hier habe ich jetzt noch eine
kräutermischung aus oregano und rosmarin
und oliven richtig richtig lecker wird
das so
dann könnte jetzt hier einfach eine
rührschüssel nehmen
dietrich vorbereitet haben sie nämlich
dank
und dann kommt jetzt hier die hefe in
die rührschüssel und ihr seht auch schon
bei pizzateig nämlich echt immer sehr
wenig hilfe weil es wirklich ausreicht
zucker drauf
heute in der tagesschau pizza brot mit
kräuter knoblauch und käse habe ich den
käse erwähnt habe ich den käse erwählt
ich habe den käse nicht allein gottes
kiesbett sticks
dann hat sich jetzt mal einen grill vor
ich habe das big green egg und bin
richtig glücklich damit weil ich einfach
sehr gut damit zurecht komme es
speichert die hitze perfekt ich kann
darin direkt oder indirekt grillen und
garn auf verschiedenen ebenen und ich
bin einfach happy denn ich weiß auch
mittlerweile wie man den greens selber
an macht ohne dass ich den murat dafür
braucht ohne grillanzünder ohne
brennspiritus und so weiter ich habe
hier die kohle und dann kommt die her
wenn die schale rein praktisch bis zur
ersten linie geht es nur das eine riesen
tag aufgeht
[Musik]
so schön verteilt und da sieht man ganz
schön dass die kohle einfach große und
kleine stücke hat sich alles gleichmäßig
erhitzt und wirklich auch lange warm
bleibt das ist nämlich wichtig das ist
einfach lange die gleiche temperatur
hält
und wenn die kohle dann verteilt ist
einfach nur an zinsen dann nehme ich mit
dem los leider dafür den gibt's mit
kabel und auch ohne tatsächlich ich habe
natürlich mal den mit kabel dar weil wir
hier auf der terrasse sind ohne kabel
muss man hat immer daran denken dass da
eben auch geladen ist aber mit dem
klappt das super ich endlich hier
einfach so zwei drei stellen macht den
grill zu und macht natürlich oben und
unten so das loch auf damit ein durchzug
herrscht und das feuer auch schnell
brennt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das war's schon dann verschließe ich den
grill hier oben ist offen unten der
schacht der muss auch geöffnet werden
damit sauerstoff rein kommt und die
kohle schön leuchten und glühen und
brennen kann dann gebt ihr jetzt das
meer langsam dazu
mit den kräutern danach salz pfeffer
olivenöl und einfach schön kneten
das vor kurzem einen assistenten den
talker denn meine hände sind zu
schmutzig für die kreuzfahrten
einfach so bis
drei stunden später 5 stunden später ein
kilo hafer später
preis erreicht danke
aber das mache ich ja nur beim salz
der vorteil ist wenn man den teig mit
der hand verknetet dann merkt man auch
immer wie die konsistenz ist also das
ist schon immer gut aber manchmal
braucht man ein bisserl weniger mehl
manchmal ein bisschen mehr je nachdem
wie exakt man das wasser ab gemessen hat
und der teig soll jetzt schön weich sein
aber auch noch nicht so weit wie hier
das heißt das medien das kommt auch
schon noch rein
nur vielleicht bleiben so 1 2 esslöffel
übrig marko
und wenn ihr dann hier diese schöne teig
kugel habt könnt ihr sie nochmal
einfetten
in die schüssel zurücklegen und den teig
abdecken bis er sich sichtlich
verdoppelt hat und ich kann in der
zwischenzeit schon mal euch die zutaten
zeigen die noch oben drauf kommen der
grill ist gleich heiß den kann ich jetzt
kurz einstellen dass er eben keine 600
guard hat sondern nur 250
perfekt denn da wird gleich knobloch
darum gegangen
dass ich hier meine zwei kleinen
gusseisen papieren ihr könnt natürlich
auch andere grillfest gefäße nehmen da
packe ich jetzt jeweils nur knoblauch
rolle rein
etwas olivenöl drüber und dann wird das
ganze erst noch vor gegart und die
knoblauchzehe die wird dann so schön
weich dass ich sie später einfach nur
ausdrücken kann das wird der hammer und
so kann man auch die zeit kurz
überbrücken bis ich dann die restlichen
zutaten habe und dann ab mit euch auf
den grill damit so richtig schön weich
garen und die geschlossenen gefäße sind
natürlich perfekt damit die dieses
knoblauch immer schön drin bleibt okay
dann richtig kurzen die nächsten zutaten
[Musik]
ich habe ich jetzt den knoblauch der
fertig gegart ist und den könnte jetzt
hier einmal halbieren und dann schön die
knoblauchzehe ausdrücken
[Musik]
man kommt hier noch olivenöl dazu und
etwas pfeffer jetzt könnt ihr das hier
so richtig schön zerdrücken und hat
einfach nicht ganz ganz tolle knoblauch
passte dann gebe ich jetzt hier noch
etwas olivenöl dazu und gerne auch salz
und pfeffer wobei ich jetzt erstmal oper
dazu geben und
wenn ihr wollt gern noch frische kräuter
ich will mal ganz kurz hier hinten
welche
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dann gebe ich die kräuter dazu und ich
finde diese methode der knoblauchbutter
echt genial denn der knoblauch ist dann
so schön passt ist der lässt sich toll
verstreichen und vor allem muss ich
ihnen ja vorher nicht drücken dann
einfach nur raus das ist so lecker so
schön
könnte auch gleich mehrere knollen zu
bereiten
[Musik]
meine knoblauch paste ist fertig habe
ich jetzt noch verschiedene käsesorten
ich nehme jetzt etwas parmesan chatter
und ein cover käse denn von ghazi und
die werden jetzt hier gerieben
[Musik]
habe ich jetzt eine richtig schöne drei
käse mischung nicht quattro von
matschies sondern 3 formation
ist das auf italienisch 3 nur durch
drainage
dann könnt ihr jetzt euren teilnehmen am
besten in vier portionen ein teil
die nachbarn sind ganz schön laut heute
also ich muss sagen fahrrad fahren wir
auch mal schön nett immer auto motorrad
jetzt einfach schön dünn ausrollen und
dann mit kräuterbutter
einstreichen
und hier kommt jetzt schön die käse
mischung drauf
habe ich jetzt hier schon mal eine pizza
stein vorgeheizt und da wird das ganze
jetzt gebacken ihr könnt aber natürlich
auch im backofen backen und die brauche
jetzt vor ungefähr 15 minuten und dann
ist sie fertig und können gleich
verkostet werden in der zeit mache jetzt
die anderen fertig
hinter uns läuft übrigens grad der
hübsche mg vorbei falls ihr kennenlernen
wollte dann schreibt ihm einfach auf
instagram
[Musik]
murat und patrick sind auch schon da und
jetzt können wir probieren und abc die
reine fertigt die andere backe ich
gleich noch aus
so viele patrick dass ich unseren
machbar so patrick meister verlor der
mann ganzen folierung von schildern
fahrzeugen düngemitteln und alles für
uns nicht geben außerdem ist er ein
großartiger künstler schlechter
fußballer guter musiker
ich hab ihm kräuter knoblauch käsebrot
gemacht vom grill alles klar ich dachte
patrick war über gekommen weil er das
essen gerochen
hat er noch gesagt hat du des
presseberichtes es nicht so wie ich
glaube gott sei dank weil sie natürlich
den ganzen tag nichts mehr arbeiten hier
hatten ganz klar kaum gehört 15
kilometer ist auf jeden fall zwischen
uns 300 meter
ich merke es in welchem er olaf h diese
drei meter zu ihm
kaum probiert über fast kalt werden
testet mal
wow
ich kenne quattro formate ich eine
trommel
ich finde es sogar noch mehr knoblauch
da habt ihr nämlich hier noch knoblauch
pastor wenn ihr wollt aber
so wenn man grillt und draußen so das
brot als beilage oder
oder hier jetzt ein salat dazu als
beilage passt schon zu schaden beinahe
ist so muss so
so der mann von sally das ist so bei
lange
sogar besser wenn
ich mir sagen unser mann von sally da
ich der mann von sally
ich war der name der man-konzern man von
sind das ist bei vielen sich auch so ein
gespeichert werden der mann von zellen
also sagen wir schalten nicht drangehen
nicht angehen macht rassistisch ist ganz
natürlich hast du auch mal handy jemand
wo draufsteht nicht dran geht ja ehrlich
jetzt schoss sascha hat es jemand von
euch werde ich habe jetzt auch schluss
auch nicht auf das net / einfach kontakt
und das ist auch auf dem handy
warum traut peter nicht angehen ich habe
vorsicht nicht drangehen
finanzamt nicht drangehen
schwiegermutter nicht rangehen
will nur geld nur im world ranking nicht
rangehen alles was ich würde sagen dann
ist das keine beilage sondern schon eine
hauptspeise zu dem man gern mal ein
salat reiche könnt oder problemen würde
ich auch sagen ich gucke jetzt gleich
wieder auf den grill denn da sind noch
ein paar vorne in der zubereitung dann
hole ich die auch gleich her und ich
finde da immer ganz schön beim grillen
draußen das nicht das ganze essen auf
einmal fertig ist sondern dass man weg
so nach und nach ganz gechillt und schon
drehen kann alles ist vorbereitet und
dann hat man schönen geselligen abend
das war grafites ihn kein bisschen was
zum schutz ja wenn ihr ehemann zu
kämpfen es geht natürlich noch unsere
deckung
[Gelächter]
mit lkws ece roller postbote also bei
uns in so außendrehs immer recht
dieses motto
religion ja also das problem ist dass du
aus dem krug nicht ausgeben kann rechts
herum oktoberfest überweisen ja oh
gott wie schnell so was her ist ein
herstellungsfehler er wollte mir nicht
glauben also macht gut bis zum nächsten
markt bis rezept findet ihr in meiner
app oder auch cellistin ist blog.de
dann machen wir unsere karaoke-party
verkaufen wir so aus dem shop ich hier
natürlich nun wir reden gerade was
wichtiger ist rot manchmal die augen
diesen coup ehrlich jetzt nur
wir hatten deutlich nämlich eine live
karaoke party mit gitarren patrick
richtig schön
blenden
[Musik]